[Applause]
hello everyone hello everyone I'm very
happy to welcome greta Sundberg to the
european parliament in our Environment
Committee I would also like to welcome
the Secretary of State a madam shot from
the Romanian presidency our team here
members of the European Parliament and
particularly knowledge mint of the
presence of madama Kurata build who is
the coordinator for children's rights in
the European Parliament this is our last
plenary and last meeting of the
Environment Committee before the May
elections and we could have not
concluded our work in a better way than
by having with us such as inspiring
young advocate of the climate cause as
Greta is there is hardly any need for
detailed introduction of Greta who is
already widely known on many levels so
I'd like to start by thanking her for
her unfailing commitment to the topic of
climate change and for having accepted
the parliaments invitation to come and
share her views in what has been and
will continue to be one of the most
important topics of our legislative work
and with no doubt one of the most
important topics of the elections for
the European Parliament lying ahead of
us
Greta has travelled a great distance on
a train from Sweden during her school
holiday to be here with us today which
is by itself already set an example of
her commitment to her beliefs in the
past few years more than ever we not
only speak but we see in practical terms
the importance of involving actors of
all ages and from all levels of the
societal ladder in actively
contributing to the environmental
solutions but also societal pressure
where such solutions are either missing
or simply not being delivered for us in
the European Parliament we know our work
we have been very ambitious maybe more
the most ambitious European institution
in setting the climate goals for Europe
for the years to come we need we know
that this ambition needs to be supported
and continued in the next Parliament's
term so that we can ask the challenges
lie ahead of us I won't say much more
because we are already a bit delayed and
I know that you are all looking forward
to listen to Greta so with no further
ado I will give you the floor to address
do you want to speak city or do you want
to stand as you wish she wants to start
okay here's the microcell have to speak
closely but he will make quiet
my name my name is Greta timbale I'm 16
years old I come from Sweden and I want
you to panic I want you to act as if the
house was on fire I have said those
words before and a lot of people had has
explained why that is a bad idea a great
number of politicians have told me that
panic never leads to anything good and I
agree to panic unless you have to is a
terrible idea but when your house is on
fire and you want to keep your house
from burning to the ground then that
does require require some level of panic
our civil of a civilization is so
fragile it is almost like a castle bent
in the sand the facade is so beautiful
but the foundations are far from solid
we have been cutting so many corners
yesterday the world watched with despair
an enormous sorrow how of them not
chewed on burnt in Paris some buildings
are more than just buildings but the
Metrodome will be rebuilt
I hope that its foundations are strong I
hope that our foundations are even
stronger but I fear they are not around
the year 2030 10 years 259 days and 10
hours away from now we will be in a
position where we set off an
irreversible chain reaction that will
most likely lead to the end of our
civilization as we know it that is
unless in that time permanent and
unprecedented changes in all aspects of
society
have taken place including a reduction
of our co2 emissions by at least 50
percent and please note that these
calculations are depending on inventions
that has not been yet invented at scale
inventions that are supposed to clear
our atmosphere of astronomical amounts
of carbon dioxide furthermore do these
calculations not include unforeseen
tipping points and feedback loops like
the experi extremely powerful methane
gas escaping from rapidly thawing Arctic
permafrost nor do they include already
rocketing warming hidden by air
pollution nor the aspect of equity or
climate justice clearly stated
throughout the Paris agreement which is
absolutely necessary to make it work on
a global scale we must also bear in mind
that these are just calculations
estimations that means that these points
of no return may occur a bit sooner or
later than that no one can know for sure
we can however be certain that they will
occur approximately in these timeframes
because these calculations are not
opinions wild guesses these projections
are backed up by scientific facts
concluded by all nations through the
IPCC nearly ever every major national
scientific body around the world
unreservedly supports the work and
findings of the IPCC we are in the midst
of the sixth mass extinction and the
extinction rate is up to ten thousand
times faster than what is considered
normal with up to 200 species becoming
extinct every single day
erosion of fertile topsoil liver
deforestation of her great forest toxic
air pollution loss of insects and
Wildlife the acidification of our oceans
these are all disastrous trends being
accelerated by a way of life that we
have are financially fortunate part of
the world see as I write simply carry on
[Applause]
[Applause]
but hardly anyone knows about these
catastrophes or understand how they are
just a few first few symptoms of climate
ecological breakdown because how could
they they have not been told or more
importantly they have not been told by
the right people and in the right way
our house is falling apart and our need
us needs our leaders need to start
acting accordingly because at the moment
they are not if our house was falling
apart our leaders wouldn't go on like
you do today you would change almost
every part of your behavior as you do in
an emergency if our house was falling
apart
you wouldn't fly around the world in
business class chatting about how the
market was sold everything with clever
small solution to specific isolated
problems you wouldn't talk about buying
and building your way out of the crisis
that has been created by buying and
building things if our house was falling
apart you wouldn't hold three emergency
breaks at summers and no emergency
summit regarding the breakdown of the
client
[Applause]
you wouldn't be arguing about facing out
coal in 15 or 11 years if our house was
falling apart you wouldn't be
celebrating that one single nation like
Ireland may soon divest from fossil
fuels you wouldn't celebrate that Norway
has decided to stop drilling for oil
outside the scenic resort of Lofoten
Islands but will continue to drill for
oil everywhere else for decades it's 30
years too late for that kinds of
celebrations if our house was falling
apart the media wouldn't be writing
about anything else the ongoing climate
and ecological crisis would make up all
the headlines if our house was falling
apart
you wouldn't say that you have the
situation under control and placed the
future living conditions for all species
in the hands of inventions that are yet
to be invented and you would not spend
all your time as a politician arguing
about Texas or brexit if the walls of
our house truly came tumbling down
surely you would set your differences
aside and start cooperating
[Music]
well our house is falling apart
and we are rapidly running out of time
and yet basically nothing is happening
everyone everything needs to change so
why waste precious time arguing about
swats and who needs to change first
everyone and everything has to change
but the bigger your platform the bigger
your responsibility the bigger your
carbon footprint
the bigger your moral duty when I tell
politicians to act now the most common
answer is that they can't do anything
drastic because that will be too
unpopular among the voters and they are
right of course since most people are
not even aware of why those changes are
required that is why I keep telling you
to unite behind the science make the
best available science at the heart of
politics and democracy the EU elections
are coming up soon and many of us who
will be affected the most by this crisis
people like me are not allowed to vote
nor are we in a position to shape the
decisions of business politics
engineering media education or science
because the time it takes for us to
educate ourselves to do that simply does
no longer exist
and that is why millions of children are
taking it to the streets school striking
for the climate to create a tension for
the climate crisis you need to listen to
us we you cannot vote you need to vote
for us for your children and
grandchildren what we are doing now can
soon no longer be undone in this
election you vote for the future living
conditions for humankind and though the
politics needed do not exist today some
alternatives are
certainly less worse than others and I
have read that some parties do not even
want me standing here today because they
so desperately do not want to talk about
climate breakdown
[Applause]
our house is falling apart the future as
well as what we have achieved in the
past is literally in your hands now but
it's still not too late to act it will
take a far-reaching vision it will take
courage it would take a fear fierce
determination to act now to lay the
foundations where we may not know all
the details about how to shape the
ceiling in other words it will take
Cathedral thinking I ask you to please
wake up and make changes required
possible to do your best is no longer
good enough we must all do the seemingly
possible and it's okay if you refuse to
listen to me I am after all just a
16-year old school girl from Sweden but
you cannot ignore the scientists or the
science or the millions of school chips
come striking children who are scum
striking for the right to a future I beg
you please do not fail on this
thank you very much great man attack
crazy for the newest Inspira hotel first
young looted Scylla Oh we'd be under did
move a teen award decoy Olli yeah dad
poor rosella horner calmly Falcon as I
said political philosopher word no Javed
stemmed from eight Europe a corner tone
for the police kokuboro Matt will tell
some him bhai mind to hell so God have
an English Court where it didn't belong
to the D ha go eager with all or in
Google test a little piddly see first
yeah thank you later for your visit here
in the European Parliament and the very
inspiring speech and I think it's of
particular importance that you represent
not only yourself but hundred thousands
of young people that are now pushing us
to do more for the climate I met a lot
of them in my constituency and I was
very impressed by the 14 year old Paul
Paul already for three years engages in
his spare time for fighting climate
change and I think you Paul and all the
others they don't deserve these nasty
words these offenses that come mainly
from elderly people they deserve support
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and of course there is this big debate
should you do it during school time or
not no I was also I was also during my
school time asked even by my teacher to
go on the street and to fight for the
support for private schools in Germany
and I did so and I think what you are
doing is much more important so I will
not hide my position in the long run of
course it should be done also outside
the school time but this is not the
topic
even in school you get not a very good
degree if you only speak about what is
not the topic the topic is climate
change and climate change is probably
the biggest challenge for our political
generation this is not my words this is
the words of our Chairman Manfred Weber
when we ratified the Paris agreement and
that's why we need to do something we
need to do much more even if we are not
always of the same opinion I think it's
important for me to say okay Europe is
not doing enough all the Member States
are not doing enough but it is important
that without Europe we wouldn't have
even the Paris agreement these are not
my words these are the words from top
stern the former chief climate adviser
of President Barack Obama he was here in
the European Parliament he said without
Europe we would be nowhere so push us to
do more but also see that without Europe
we wouldn't be at least in this position
for the future I have two important
issues and I hope you and your fellows
your your like-minded young people we
can work together we want to be climate
neutral European Commission has
presented a strategy European Parliament
has supported this but the Member States
are not yet ready and we need the Member
States to do something concrete to do
action and that's why I think we should
work together to push the heads of
states a Heads of Government they need
to do something to become climate
neutral and not only discussing next
year but starting now and the second
point which is very close to my heart
and which I'm addressed in my
constituency by schoolchildren every
week
why is a V Asian not doing more to help
our climate
it is completely unfair that when you go
by train when you go by bus you pay a
lot of taxes and fees and when you go
for aviation aviation has only to
contribute 15% under the emission
trading 15% 85%
of the allowances they get for free the
European Parliament is in favor for
changing this but even in the Commission
and in the concert there are people that
think this is already too much and I
think we need to do more and we cannot
in this circumstances discuss even about
abolishing some responsibilities that
the aviation industry has we need to do
to do more and I hope we can work
together with all the young people for
this thank you very much thank you very
much mr. Leeson our next speaker is mrs.
dolly Greta
thank you for being here I'm
representing the Socialists and
Democrats but I'm also here as a mother
of two children one age five years and
another one age two years and when you
share your concern on the future that
people your age and even younger people
will have I feel the same remorse and
the same feelings that you are getting
because today you see here around you a
room full of people who are cheering
what you are saying but unfortunately
it's not always like this
in the sense that when we come to the
crunch of it when we come to specific
legislations that can actually deliver
we end up discussing things which try to
shoot down ambition so it's not the
first time and I'm sure that colleagues
following me can also speak from their
experience it's not the first time that
when we are discussing real legislations
that can make a difference we end up
shooting down and going back from that
ambition because of pressure also from
different lobbyists I'm saying this
after I worked on the legislation to
reduce co2 emissions from passenger cars
and light commercial vehicles but I'm
sure that colleagues have other
experiences as well that they can speak
about and you say you are just a school
girl of 16 years of age I come from
Malta the smallest island States
European Union and it's not about the
age or where you come from but it's
about the third did that
nation to actually make a change and
actually push for that change to happen
and from what I saw when I was following
you and from what I'm seeing today that
determination you have and you have a
lot of that determination and it is
leaving an impact on many other students
around the world not only students but
also the older generation I've seen
young people going out in the streets
even in my country to actually make the
voice heard when it comes to climate in
action you say that as a 16 year old
you're not allowed to vote and there are
some member states that are allowing 16
year-olds to vote and I think that we
need to make much more of a pressure on
that Walt as one of those countries
Austria as another country this is not a
decision for people who are older in age
but decisions in elections are taken and
will have an impact on people who today
are 16 year old and in five years time
will be 21 year olds you are the ones
who will take the brunt of the decisions
that are taken today and I'm taking this
opportunity because I believe that even
as European Parliament we need to make
sure that we push for young people your
age to actually have a voice in the
decisions that are taken and I'm glad to
hear my colleagues say that climate
change is the biggest challenge cause I
believe that it is the biggest challenge
we have and that we need to actually act
on it and if I may away from the camera
lenses and the camera flashes that we
are seeing today I wish like we all
realize that this is not only about
words but it is about action because if
we do not care of our planet will not
have economies to take care of or jobs
to take care of I'm saying this because
many times we hear also leaders of
countries within the European itself
making nice features but they're not
actually acting upon those speeches and
my colleague was quoting some different
people I would like to close off with a
quote you said the reason
because it is a quote that remained
impressed in my mind you said we must
told you the generations accountable and
they cannot continue risking our future
we need to get angry and then we have to
transform that anger into action and it
is that action we actually require to
actually change things for the better
thank you
[Applause]
thank you now mr. de miss maca yes H I
think I will I will speak in my mother
tongue if if I may so I will speak in
Dutch you ever think about the ACA so I
represent the easier group here father
and a grandfather I would like to
welcome you here to the European
Parliament you have set things in
movement you really have got a lot of
young people who are very enthusiastic
and working hard to combat climate
change and change in Flanders a lot of
people are in the street as well and I
welcome this commitment on the part of
young people now I think the political
commitment commitment also that does
start from our concern a green for
Flanders and goes back to the 1980s and
I think that there still some of that
action left 30 years later and there has
been a lot of work done to contribute to
climate protection and and there's the
work that's been done to reduce use of
plastics as well and that we have this
energy black package and this week we'll
be voting on the first year to law in
relation to vehicles and I think that
the economy and ecology have to be
reconciled through realistic and
ambitious targets that's the only way
really my party in my group will do what
it can to achieve this energy a
transition and our policy is not just a
policy to protect a crime
and the environment but we want to
protect jobs as well that's the
innovation and creativity we need to be
able to do what we can to adapt and to
adjust and I'm sure that we can do that
we need our young people for that to
come up with new solutions to do more to
achieve a circular economy and I regret
the defeatist attitude on the part of
many people I think that every day
people are working to find solutions and
they are finding solutions that can help
to combat to try and climate change and
in my own country we have there is a the
11 end University working hard to come
up with solutions in relation to in
getting the moisture and harnessing the
moisture from the air that is a one
example but there are many others as bio
technology and there's a nuclear energy
as part of the energy emits as well I
think there is so much that can be done
and all this is very good but of course
the that we need a global challenge to
write to this environmental challenge
and I have I think that young people do
have that force of innovation and that
they will do more carry on doing more to
convey the messages to everyone else
thank you very much you can keep your
headphones oh because I'm going to speak
in greatest native tongue hey great
hello and welcome to the European
Parliament it would be a bit more fun if
my name was Hansel because then we would
be Hansel and Gretel stepping out into
the big forest trying to make life
difficult for the Wicked Witch of
climate change
unfortunately Hansel is not my name my
name is Niels I'm called Nicky and I'm
sure as you can hear from my accent in
Swedish that I'm from Finland I sound a
bit like what the Swedes usually say the
moomintroll sound like
now you've come to the right place
because if there is one European
institution that does try to change life
when we talk about climate and the
environment then this is the place we
will be making all the important
decisions in the future as well and we
will be able to make the reality that
you mentioned our future I usually say
that I'm not here for my own benefit I'm
here for my grandchildren I have three
grandchildren they're slightly older
than you and I have three other
grandchildren who are a bit younger than
you and if when I now go home to Finland
at least my eldest grandchild will ask
me whether I actually spoke to Greta and
I can now say yes I did I promise to
become a better grandfather and a better
parliamentarian in trying to deal with
these tasks now for the past five years
we have taken a number of important
decisions and you're probably right when
you say that we haven't done enough but
we have tried to become stricter on the
emissions trading we have tried to make
commitments in terms of transport and
construction to make it easier to reach
our targets we have made decisions on
land use we've fought with our friends
here around the table about emissions
from vehicles but then we have a very
specific problem we all were fairly much
in agreement that we need electric
vehicles in the future but if they are
being fuelled with dirty electricity
then they actually lead to more
emissions than diesel fueled cars so
this means that we need to put a great
deal of effort into overhauling our
electricity supply system and that will
be one of our big challenges over the
coming years I do promise you one thing
I will visit you in Sweden when we have
made the decisions that you demand of us
it may not be tomorrow or the day after
it may take us some years but I see
as you can hear from the rounds of
applause here but everyone here thinks
that you're doing the right thing and we
want to support you thank you
thank you very much next speaker is mr.
Eckhardt welcome later turn back and
thank you I know you hate it when
politicians thank you but for one thing
I really want to thank you is that we
know that the upcoming elections will be
about climate change today another poll
was released indicating that a big
majority of European citizens for them
to go to the voting booth for the
European elections will be on the basis
of climate change and this is really
partly because of all your great work
and all the students and the Friday's
for future and that is something that we
have to thank you for certainly coming
from a green party where we where we've
been fighting this issue for a long
while and not always been as successful
as you would have liked to see and maybe
that is now I can turn to my colleagues
and of course I could now turn very
cynical in looking at the past in all
the different votes that we had all the
different discussions we had and I
didn't notice that urgency that much as
we see it today in the room but maybe
it's better to look forward with all of
us here when we are in July going to
vote on the new precedence of the
European Commission and a lot of you
will come back everyone hopes I hope
that everyone will remember this day
when we were applauding kata tunberg for
her speech talking about that the world
is at stake
but that also means that we have done to
look at the program of the new European
Commission whether they really want to
change policies
policies to phase out coal policies to
put a real price on carbon policies to
make aviation really pay policies to
make sure that the European budget
doesn't pay one cent to fossil fuels
policies that is really greening our
agriculture which we have not done until
now and thank you for the applause but I
want your vote on that program of the
new President of the European Commission
in July because then only that applause
really means something and now I turn to
the Commissioner because you still can
have one chance in September you will go
to New York to the UN summit on climate
change today is a good moment you can
promise that you will go to New York
where you will promise to say Europe
will increase its climate target for
2030 are you going to do that and for
the presidency and for the presidency
because you will have your future of
Europe summit in C be on the 9th of May
will you make sure that in that summit
indeed the council and all the Member
States will adopt its climate neutral
plans for 2050 including and updates and
an increase of our emission target for
2030 only then this meeting has been
successful because then we really put
words into action here at the council
and at the Commission and thank you for
that great a turn back
[Applause]
Thank You takeout now for three minutes
madam Boylan hi Greta I'm Lynn Boyle and
I'm representing the Goo Engl Group and
I can't say how pleased I am to see you
here today because the events of the
last month have probably summed up the
contradictions that we have an EU
climate policy because the political
groups that wanted to stop you from
addressing them are the same political
groups that have decided against
revoking access to ExxonMobil to the
Parliament you speak truth to power
Greta ExxonMobil spent millions
subverting the truth vested interests we
know have captured the political
majority they have convinced them that
we can tackle climate change while
maintaining perpetual growth and already
we know that we are using more resources
than is sustainable the World Bank and
the OECD are telling us that we can
still grow by 3% per year this is
madness it is absolute absurdity the
economy cannot be treated as a separate
entity in its own right unconnected to
everything else we cannot leave nature
out of the conversation when we talk
about tackling climate change because
climate change is the biggest crisis
that we're facing in humankind and we
have to stop listening to the corporate
interests and instead as Greta said
unite around the science and I have
listened with great interest to what you
have said today Greta and you mentioned
my own country Ireland and how it is
divesting from fossil fuels but while
it's divesting from fossil fuels are
still issuing extra extraction licenses
to fossil fuel companies it's still
planning Dutch forging ahead with an LNG
gas terminal so what you want from all
of us who are in this room the people
who have the political mandates is to
fight for the emergency response to
climate change that's I assume what you
came here today not to be patronized not
to have us all nod in agreement you want
us to act on the political
Monday that we've been given and to take
deep far-reaching measures that are
required and that means leaving fossil
fuels in the ground it does not mean
pumping millions of EU euros into gas
infrastructure
it means ramping up our ambition so that
we stay within the 1.5 degrees and
climate change if we can have emergency
conferences for banking crises and
breakfasts we can have it for climate
change - we need a credible path that
leads us towards carbon net neutrality
well before 2050 we need less extractive
production less consumption we want
localization over globalization in other
words it's time that the EU powered down
so I commend you Greta for the stance
that you've taken and the inspiration
that you've given to young people across
the world including in all of the EU
countries and as I said I say that to
not patronize you and I say it sincerely
that I almost do better as an elected
rep but every single one of us in this
room must do better
thank you very much
Thank You mr. fettuccine just two
minutes Graham that's I was speaking
Italian sub headphones para gratia
gratia great thank you thank you very
much greater I'd like to thank you
indeed for your presence and for what
you had to say and also involving
everybody in this particular discussion
and I think this is absolutely necessary
thank you so much and I'd like to
mention that of course this has been
done by a young girl a young girl who's
living the life of a young girl and she
has brought forward all of these
particular issues to all of us and I
think indeed with though it's absolutely
necessary to understand that there are
so many falsehoods behind all of this
particular discussion that's taken place
in other words so much has been
concealed with regard to all of this and
nothing has been done nothing has been
done before and indeed your words and
your contribution is extremely important
at this particular front so panic I
think really as you said this is a
moment for panic in many many ways we
have to look at all that is out there we
have to look at the then the issues that
are there and we have to fight against
them fight against cars fight against
all of this all of these emission
producing mechanisms that have been this
entire structure has to be gotten rid of
and a young girl a young girl brings
before us these particular issues and
indeed we have to be ever so grateful to
you Greta for bringing forward these
issues that nobody has mentioned Thank
You Missy Missy don't go so well thank
you very much chair as often in human
life excesses in one direction are
followed by excesses in the opposite
direction I think that your generation
is aware of the damage that has been
caused by the
previous generations and this is a very
good thing it's absolutely essential but
I think that we had the
industrialization and intensive farming
aimed at trying to achieve as much
profit as possible but I think that we
don't want this to be followed by an
opposite excess and let's be reasonable
here I think we're right to be have a
indignation but we have to be measured
in our words we have to base ourselves
on a science and we cannot be based on
shock sentences and on our emotions
alone I think that we have to be aware
of a disinformation and we have to be
we've protect ourselves as well from
lobbying and from the finance world I
think that we have to have to have X
excellence we have to aim at that
otherwise we can be ridiculous I think
that we can't get it wrong today and we
have got it wrong in the past sometimes
that we have to avoid all form of
hysteria we really do we mustn't be
irresponsible at all now the last of
report by the French agronomy Institute
in relation to carbon footprint of
forests drew attention to the fact that
there were was a lack of reliable or
calculations we do have to take your
measures that we have to invest in
innovation that's true but we have to
take account of economic balances we
have to take over SMEs p.m. and we have
to take account of jobs as well we have
to save - also we are relying on no
generation of cattle generation to do
more thing thank you very much so that
concludes the round of speakers on
behalf of the political groups and now
I'd like to you by the representative of
Romanian presidency the state secretary
Madame shot to commit to increase the
national determined contributions in
this severe summit
this house repeatedly insisted upon so
madam thank you madam chair
I would like to thank the European
Parliament for inviting the Romanian
presidency to this meeting first of all
I would like to take this opportunity to
salute miss Greta Sundberg for her
engagement in the fight against climate
change and for raising awareness about
the issue particularly among other young
people and the responsibility that we
have for our planet and for our citizens
especially the future generations more
than just launching a movement and
inspiring a generation you are also
awakening the consciousness of older
generations including the parents
teachers politicians and decision makers
of this world we are all aware of the
scale and urgency of the challenges
posed by the climate change we are
already witnessing the devastating
impacts on climate change all over the
world and yet as Greta has pointed out
many times action to prevent
irreversible and catastrophic climate
disruption remains unsophisticated
by the IPCC special report
global warming of 1.5 degrees Celsius
without stepping up global climate
action global average temperature
increase could reach 2 degrees Celsius
soon after 2060 and continue rising
afterwards
it is therefore urgent to Stratton the
global response to the threat of climate
change and the European Union is
determined to help raise a global action
and lead
way at the meeting of the European
Council last month our heads of state
and government reiterated the EU's
commitment to the Paris agreement the
European Union with its present
ambitious policy framework continues to
lead the way on climate action it is
broadly on track to achieve its 2020
greenhouse gas renewable energy and
energy efficiency targets it has also
agreed on ambitions target for further
reducing its greenhouse gas emissions by
2030 and those targets have now been
translated into EU legislation in
particular those laws will ensure
continued emission reductions in the
industrial and power sector and the
Bish's binding national reduction
targets for all EU member states in
other sectors such as buildings
transport and waste combined with other
sectoral policies for example concerning
the development of renewable energy
energy efficiency requirements and
carbon dioxide emission standards for
motor vehicles this guarantees that you
will achieve its 2030 targets of
reducing its greenhouse gas emission but
least 40% it is compared to 1990 and
thus also fulfill its nationally the
turn contribution to the Paris agreement
with a view to the preparation of the
EU's long term strategy the council is
currently discussing a communication
presented by the Commission in the
communication the Commission analyzes
various scenarios for long-term emission
reductions those pathways would achieve
greenhouse gas emissions reduction
ranging from 80 percentages to 100
percentages within the EU by 2
50 the communication is actively debated
within the council the Romanian
presidency wishes to enable as broad and
comprehensive debates for all relevant
sectors environment energy transport
industry and competitiveness agriculture
and finance the ministerial debates held
so far have highlighted the fact that
there is a share recognition of the need
for action the European Council has also
emphasised the importance of the youth
submitting an ambitious long-term
strategy by 2020 striving for climate
neutrality in line with a Paris
agreement moving toward a low-carbon
economy will require major changes we
need to be managed carefully in order to
ensure that the transition is a just and
socially balanced way for all the
council will continue an intensifying
discussion on the long term vision we
also look forward to the high-level
events planned at international level in
2019 which provide an opportunity to
mobilize political will to raise global
ambition such as the UNFCCC secretaries
general climate Simon in September 2019
which brings me to the end of my
comments whereby I would again like to
thank the Parliament for organizing this
discussion I close by special thanks to
Greta
for being the inspiration and for
spreading the message about climate
change
you have also helped to give a voice to
the concerns of the young people notably
by sparking the now-famous school
strikes for climate which have spread
around the world I hope and believe that
those strikes will become unnecessary as
in
in global and you action against climate
change will help to put us on the right
path toward the long-term goals of the
Paris agreement Europe and the world
will need bright well-trained and
committed young people to build a
climate neutral future thank you thank
you very much thank you for your
commitment and the recognition of
Europe's role commissioner areas Canada
thank you for joining us today at this
meeting with gratitude mark you are
responsible for putting forward so much
decisive legislation to tackle the
climate change topic so you have the
floor Madam President all our members of
European Parliament ladies and gentlemen
I would like to find greater tunberg not
only for coming today to affirm
Parliament but also for giving face and
voice for young people taken to the
streets in growing numbers demanding
more climate action we are calling for
more action now and rightly so because
the urgency is clear you want us to act
and rightly so because when the type
your generation will be in the driving
seat
in politics in public service in
business and elsewhere it will be too
late to stop climate change your message
is very clear and we listen to you very
clearly to me your message is an
encouragement to do more and for that I
thank you we do have claim leadership in
this and we must assume it in full we
have acted we continue to act but now we
must act more and faster we have based
our action on the latest available
science and we have always shocked to
foster multilateral solutions to global
problems thanks to our commitment we now
have the Paris agreement and this means
a multilateral consensus to contain
global rise in temperature to well below
two degrees and to make efforts to stay
at 1.5 but we also know that there is a
major gap between the goals of the Paris
agreement and the current efforts to
achieve them the bad news
is that sign Stella's at the same at 1.5
will mean painful adaptation but we will
still leave us with a word we would
recognize it tell us that accepted two
degrees would mean an already very
different and very different world
and beyond this science tell us that the
youth of today would live in a world we
would not recognize these are the
inescapable implications of the IPCC a
special report on 1.5 from Lhasa
but the good news is that the same IPCC
report also tells us that pathways
though was well below two degrees and
even 1.5 are still possible this is
possible if we decide to start now the
deep transformation of our economy and
our society that scientists tell us is
necessary the report concluded that to
be on a pathway to 1.5 with no or
limited overshoot human-induced co2
emissions need to drop to Net Zero
around 2050 and the world needs to reach
Net Zero greenhouse gas emissions what
we call crime and neutrality sometime
between 2060 and 28 to achieve this it
is clear that developing news the lies
nations should reach climate neutrality
very much early
it is for this reason and building on
action already taken mainly the recently
adopted European Union legislation to
achieve our objectives for 2030 that the
Commission has proposed to make the
European Union economy co2 negative
before 2050 and to achieve net zero
greenhouse gas emissions kleitman
neutrality by 2050 our gen generation
Astra is black according to science and
the European Commission has the liberal
and your active mobilization is and will
continue to be an essential support to
our common action I am very satisfied
that the European Parliament already
endorsed the objective of climate
neutrality by 2050 and I look forward to
hearing the same from the European
Council when they will discuss this
issue in their meeting in June 2019 a
mr. a code you will be you can be sure I
will spare no effort to achieve that yes
but I also trust that this debate will
happen everywhere and not only in our
institutions
because changing our economic system
requires active Democratic participation
and this is all the more important as we
approach the European Parliament
elections and it matters to Europeans as
mr. as I could point it out a new poll
released today shows that as many as
seventy seven percent of potential
voters identify climate change as an
important criterion when deciding who to
vote for at the May European elections
these elections offer the opportunity
for euros political parties for their
spitting candidate to put climate action
at the center of the campaigns and to
explain to our citizens also to our
generations what has already been
achieved and what more we still need to
do and it is urgent that Europe the
European institutions member states
civil society and business agree on
objective of climate neutrality by 2050
at the latest before the end of the tear
n it is urgent because we may have 30
years left to achieve it but we only
have the next years to develop and
decide the actions and policies that we
need and start the massive investments
that this transformation requires in
many aspects of the European society we
have legislated ambitious standards to
cut emissions from road transport we
have a legislature on renewables energy
efficiency we have changed elasticity
markets but we know that we must go
further and that these targets and
obligations we must go further than this
Turkish an obligation we have to go
climb a new trail by 2050 and we also
know that we must find the right pace
for transition as fast as we can but at
the same time we have to preserve and
enhance the condition for the prosperity
of our citizens and ensure that the
transition is fair and that no region no
work and no citizen is led behind both
signs in our own analysis so that all of
this is possible we will succeed we will
offer other countries an effective model
to stop climate change without
sacrificing prosperity and development
every inhalation
that's a critical global issue to face
will war peace and reconciliation
the quest for democracy nuclear
disarmament global hunger or
from whole climate chain is the issue
for our generation
so my message to you general appearances
please keep up the pressure keep raising
the voices for the climate the voices
that would carefully have listened to
the end European Parliament keep
engaging with decision-makers in all
European Union countries on how we in
Europe will make the transition to climb
a neutrality a reality keep it up so
that our generation will rise to your
expectation it's a war feature but most
importantly it's your future well thank
you very much to all of you for coming
to our last environment meeting it was
really spectacular and I think it's the
right way to finish a very hard and
important work we had in the parliament
in a dis mandate see you in the next one
with strong forces to fight for climate
and to engage as many young people as
possible into our next future world
Thank You Greta for coming and good luck
with your endeavors